Pope Francis has criticized
International leaders saying they failed
to address war and inequality an Italian
newspaper has published excerpts of his
book due to be released on Tuesday now
the head of the Roman Catholic Church
calls for major reforms that the United
Nations saying that it must find new
ways to resolve conflict as the war in
Ukraine goes on and he says the
coronavirus pandemic has exposed global
inequality with wealthy Nations getting
priority for the vaccines the pope also
says leaders must ReDiscover their
purpose of serving Humanity
Gerard O'Connell is Vatican
correspondent for America magazine he's
also the author of the election of Pope
Francis and inside account of the
conclave That Changed History and joins
me now from Rome good to have you with
us Mr O'Connell on the program I mean in
recent days we've heard the pope speak
out about sort of the inhumanity shown
towards migrants a veiled response
perhaps to the incoming Italian
government and perhaps a precursor to
what was in this book
well yes he's spoken about migrants
because we've got the worst humanitarian
crisis in terms of migrants and refugees
since the second world war and Pope
Francis has spoken very clearly that
we're effectively on the brink of a
third world war he speaks about we've
got a World War in pieces currently
being conducted and we're at the risk of
a third world war if the war in Ukraine
continues and so he's he's appealing
very strongly to
to International organizations like the
United Nations but also to leaders of
governments in different countries to
resolve this quickly by diplomatic means
otherwise it risks spinning out of
control and dragging the rest of the
world with it how is one of the points
in the book yeah indeed I mean how do
you sort of place him as leader of the
Catholic church and being so vocal
compared to other popes before him
because other popes have always alluded
to the inhumanity to groups of people
and Pope John Paul II always had a go at
the former Soviet Union in some shape or
form but where do you place Pope Francis
in the context of what we've been
experiencing these last three years and
certainly within the last three or six
months
well he's very articulate because he's
looking first of all what is happening
to people on the ground and he's seen
that in in Ukraine a country where you
had 44 million people 11 million are
either refugees or internally displaced
people and he sees the cruelty that is
beyond description with the bombing of
schools with the bombing of uh
kindergartens with the bombing of
hospitals and he's saying this has to
stop and but he doesn't see anybody
stopping it he doesn't seem anybody
working to stop it he sees 40 countries
or more helping to give arms to Ukraine
to defend itself and he says yes Ukraine
has a right to defend itself but if the
war continues where is it going to end
and in this book he speaks about the
danger of nuclear war he says Where will
this take Humanity
so while he gives us food for thought
one wonders if he can't get through to
the politicians Mr O'Connell can he get
through to his colleagues within you
might say the Christian faith the
Orthodox Church in Russia the Orthodox
Church in Greece that have a great deal
of Sway and influence within the sort of
Slavic countries and the Slavic thought
process
yes it is publicly disagreed with the
leader of the Orthodox Church in in
Russia patriarchiro he says you can't be
the acolyte the altar boy of of the
government of Putin you have to be a
pastor to your people and so he's been
very explicit in this and he's trying he
went to Kazakhstan some weeks ago he's
going to Bahrain very soon
he's trying to get the the leaders of
the different religions together to come
together to work for peace he said
religion is to
support promote peace not to be a cause
of conflict and this is where he
disagrees with Patrick Carroll in Russia
whose blessing the troops going to war
and saying your Patriots and you you
will go to heaven if if uh if you die
it'll be interesting to see um how his
book is received and certainly what
comes of his visits in the next few
weeks Gerald O'Connell thanks so much
for joining us from Rome
thank you very much